I'm gay.
I'm gonna get so fat.
Life is full of change.
And that's all a lot easier
if you've got people who love you,
helping you face
whatever life throws at you.
Mmm. So good.
I want a cheeseburger.
This is a special soup called pho.
You told me not to say that word.
It is delicious.
This is the food of your people.
Can I get you anything else?
Actually, we're just trying
to teach our daughter about your country.
And as I'm saying that,
I'm hoping you're from Vietnam.
I was born there.
So was Lily.
Oh, it's a beautiful country.
My family still lives there.
I hate Vietnam. Lily, honey, we don't hate.
I hate Vietnam.
Okay, We need just a second.
Lily, that was rude. I want to go home.
No, it's important that you celebrate
the culture of your ancestors.
You are Vietnamese.
No, I'm not. I'm gay. I'm gay.
Honey, no, you're not gay.
You are just confused. Oh, my God.
What is wrong with me?
It's like, Oh, please.
We have tons of lesbian friends that you
would reference our friends and not us.
Also gay.
We should just go. No, Nobody's
going anywhere
We should just go. No, nobody's
until she finishes the whole soup.
Gloria, it's fine.
No, no, it's not fine.
That's the problem with this country.
Nobody cares where they come from.
They just want cheeseburgers
and bread, school.
And they have forgotten about Colombia.
Okay, I can't help but feel that
maybe you're bringing something
to the table
that's possibly not at all about Lily.
I think you're right.
It's just that I feel like
I'm losing my children to America.
They're just going to grow up
and become boring old white people.
Most of our friends are white, actually.
Okay, can everybody just calm down
and go back to their own conversations?
Just. Thank you.
There you are. Okay. Where's Dylan?
Oh, Mom.
Oh, we need someone to take the picture.
Harsh.
What was that?
Don't we always have the fire on?
No, I'm sure we do.
Last year, we use it to finish cooking
Claire's turkey pieces.
Jay,
go turn it on. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Everybody, 12 and under out.
Well, honey, what's going on?
Dylan's stuck in the chimney.
Oh. Why?
He's dressed up as Santa.
He was gonna
hand presents out to the kids.
Awww.
Don’t tell them now.
I wanna be with you.
Tell us what?
Nothing. It can wait.
No, it can't. Please.
My organs are shutting down.
Okay, fine. I.
We have an announcement.
Dylan and I are having a baby.
Are they smiling?
You're pregnant? Yes.
We're really happy about it.
Why wouldn't you be? Wow.
Mom?
It's...
It's a lot to process at once, and --
A baby.
Unbelievable.
Oh. Oh,
Congratulations!
You handled it a lot better than I did
back in the day.
Ohh. Outside, on the inside I’m you.
Can somebody save my life?
Oh, yeah. Cam, grab a foot.
Yep!
Phil and Claire, as godparents
are you ready to help the parents
of this child in their duties?
We are.
Do you renounce Satan?
I do.
Renounce him.
and all his works.
I do renounce them.
Hey, hey!
And all his empty
promises.
Oh, my God.
[Screaming]
I do renounce them.
Godfather,
is it your wish
for this child to be baptized?
It is.
[Screaming]
We're thinking about getting a cat.
Oh, well, isn't that wonderful?
I'm thrilled for you both.
This is a heck of a decision.
You have my full support.
Okay.
I think it'll be a perfect addition
to the family.
I know. I'll love
the heck out of little bugger.
I'm just hoping that little one over there
doesn't get jealous.
Oh, this little one will be just fine.
Now that he knows where he stands,
in the shadow of your new baby.
What's he talking about?
He's talking about I am pregnant.
Oh, come on.
You gotta be kidding me.
Oh, gross.
I know Grandpa can still do it.
Don't be disrespectful, Luke.
Anyone could do it with Gloria.
And if you were to say it on your all
ways, to be happy about it,
I can raise it on my own.
I have done it
before, and I can do it now.
I come from a very long line of strong
Latin
woman
whose husbands are nowhere to be found.
Are you done?
Yes. Can I say something?
Go on.
That's the greatest news I've ever heard.
It is? I spent the day
hearing what my future
had in store for me,
and I didn't like one bit of it.
Felt like my life was ending.
And now you're telling me
that I get to have a new start?
With the woman of my dreams.
I think I'm gonna cry.
Way ahead of you.
Can you believe this?
I know they wouldn't
even let us get a cat.
It's going to be great.
I'm going to get so fat.
Mostly great
Friends.
Family.
Really?
What you know I cry at weddings.
Oh, no.
What? Stop, stop crying.
What just because you have ice
water in your veins, doesn’t mean that --
No. No. Lily?! No.
Daddy’s not sad.
Daddy!
Daddy, --
[Bleep]
[Laughter]
See? I told you it was funny.
[Bleep noises]
[Laughter]
Hi, honey.
I'm sorry I'm late.
We had a whole incident at the warehouse.
The paint mixer blew up.
Luckily,
I had these overalls in my office.
Oh, you're mad, aren't you?
Mad?!
I mean, was this the best Valentine's Day
we've ever had?
No. Was it the worst? Yes.
I gave you a great gift.
I tried to surprise you at the office.
You repaid the offer
by making a reservation at a truck stop
and dressing up like Tom Sawyer.
But, hey, maybe this happens
to everyone, Claire.
Romance fizzles, magic dies.
At least we can mark the exact time
it happened to us.
Thanks to my new watch,
which only a switchboard operator
from the 1950s could keep wound.
You mean this watch
the Houdini handcuffs.
I've been taking magic lessons
as a Valentine's surprise.
Wait a minute.
The supposed hidden salesmen
at your office, the great Majestic.
Of course
I didn't recognize them without a floor
length robe covered in question marks.
And we also really do have a reservation
at that really nice place down the street.
So we should probably get your check.
Excuse me. Could we get the check?
But, are you really dressed for --
So wonderful. Oh.
Oh, well, come on, honey,
we should get going. Wait.
Do you have the key?
No, but you do.
I don't deserve you.
Okay, everybody squeeze in.
Squeeze in for the picture.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay.
All right, Perfect.
I got it.
[Laughter]
Oh, I kind of don't want to let go.
Yeah, me neither.
I mean it’s Mitch and Cam now, but
It’s these three next
Who knows when we will all be together again.
Why is this so hard?
We've done this, like, seven times already
today.
It's hard because not
everybody gets to have what we had.
Oh, Mitchell,
I put the skating trophy in your suitcase
I want you to have it first so that I know
you'll come back.
Okay, um..
I'm going to set an example
to be the first one to let go.
It was awful.
Life is full of change.
Some big, some small.
I learned a long time ago.
You can fight it.
You can try to make the best of it.
And that's all a lot easier
if you've got people
who love you, helping you face
whatever life throws at you.
At least
that's what helps me sleep at night.